good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
it is a beautiful day here i'm riding on
a friday high and i had an amazing dream
that me and brett eldredge were
lovers so it's just a good day for me
you guys were simpatico
erotico
how does the course of that song go
that's like it no are you talking about
um
forgetting sarah marshall nope i'm
talking about that
bad teacher perry and nine oh okay
confusing i thought you were
inside of you inside of you
how i longed to be is it wrong to be
inside of you that's a beautiful ballad
sickening good morning good morning um i
feel extra smiley today because my teeth
sort of hurt
because i wore my night cards for the
first time last night
alert nerd alert weird alert working on
myself
of course from the inside out my teeth
are super crooked that's a fun fact
about me and with every passing day they
become more crooked
only your bottom teeth yeah and so i've
had this conversation with my dentist
about do i want to fix them and i
actually like think they're kind of cool
quirky but they're getting like rapidly
more crooked so now i
have night guards so that the way that
they look today they will not become
more crooked than this
yeah so that's exciting but they were
super tight
yeah painful and if you like if you are
not diligent and you like let a few
weeks go by when you put it in it really
hurts
yeah but that was like what it felt like
last night because it was my first time
but i'm i'm looking forward to bettering
my
um oral health oral health is so
important
yeah so important so important we have a
fabulous show for you guys today fast
five
southern charm finale was last night and
it was a weird episode
yeah there's a lot to talk about and i
look forward to
talking about it i also look forward to
the fact that today's friday it's just
like
i woke up this morning so so tired of
course
and just really any other way to wake up
but like i don't know recently
especially with bruno
sometimes i wake up due to things going
on around me and it's not a bad way to
go
but it was just like all of a sudden it
was nine o'clock and i had to get my ass
up
um but just knowing that tomorrow i'll
be able to sleep in it's such a
beautiful thing plus i'm hosting shabbat
at my apartment tonight yes
uh first time at my new apartment and
i'm like so excited nervous it's such a
tough crowd and like
i just really want to hit it out of the
park and i'm also filming a vlog for our
patreon about my first time hosting like
i'm really
inspired by um barefoot contessa to like
make some content around hosting
that's really smart and the vlog is
going really well so far i've already
set up my table
um i'm doing all the food prep today and
serving and the whole thing today
um but i'm really excited about it so
head over to patreon.com morning toast
because that will be up probably this
weekend some good weekend content
viewing
your third episode of the month hope you
enjoyed the first two first two was
general q
a answering all of the questions that
you guys have about us miscellaneous
questions
and they were really fun i hope you guys
got a taste of us
um so earlier in the week we talked a
little bit about morgan wallen's album
and i said i just
had not found the time to really not
made the time
sure to just give it my all and i don't
want to do it half-ass but i've now been
i'm going
on day three of just like exclusively
listening to it
and wow yeah
masterpiece sickening stand in my boots
what's your favorite song what are your
standouts so far it's hard because
there's
so many songs but like but i love that
song like
red redneck red lights red
beard red redneck red lettuce red dirt
red letters yes
yes um let me pull up my spotify
obviously stand in my boots is like so
beautifully sickeningly stunning um
love that so much uh 865 is good okay
um it's just so hard like i literally oh
and i love the songs on there that i
already knew like seven summers which
i'm obsessed with and more than my
hometown
um yes red next red letters red beer
none of these are like
sounding like things i remember my
favorite two are outlaw
okay oh is that with becca ben yeah yes
agreed
so good and wonder about the wind
i'm not there yet i'm not like i just
the way that i do it is like i put it on
and i listen to it i don't really like
pay attention to the song but sometimes
i'm like oh
this is really good and then i add it to
my like and you look up like oh this is
the song
yeah and then i'll notice that it will
happen a lot with the same song oh and
that's how you know it's a good song and
that's how you know but a thirty out
thirty seconds
does she know that was good that's good
right
i'm so excited for enchanted too a 30
song
album is really hard to digest no but
like we need
more 30 song albums i agree more working
for more
speaking of music we have some music
news today because the olivia rodrigo
joshua bassett sabrina carpenter
trifecta has officially completed
because now we have a song from sabrina
carpenter
and i have a lot to say about it i have
a lot to say that is our top story of
the day and so
if you would like we can just get right
into sure
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
you know what i'm not in the mood to
like do a skit okay so today's episode
is brought to you by proactive get that
clear skin feeling proactive acne
treatment systems have clinically proven
ingredients to clear skin
and their dermatologist tested to be
gentle there's a proactive for you
dermatologist tested proactive has three
different acne fighting systems
designed for your skin type i feel like
for as long as i know proactive has just
been like the answer to acne i remember
simple proactive yeah and like since we
were kids like i knew a lot of kids
growing up who used it and now it's like
everyone it's just the go-to system it's
so it's proven because
pimples do not happen overnight acne
always seems to appear out of nowhere
like i don't know the night before your
you know show at the beacon or the night
before your birthday party always but it
can actually be weeks in the making
before it shows up on your skin
from stubborn breakouts to occasional
pimples proactive has you covered
life is stressful right now so i think
adult acne is on the rise
especially with mask knee yes proactive
combines gentle skin care paired with
clinically proven acne fighting
ingredients to treat your skin
you can find the right proactive system
for you from their three different
system
designed for your skin type the first is
the proactive solution which is the
original system suitable for all skin
types
proactive plus is for sensitive skin
types and proactive md is their
prescription
strength system for stubborn breakouts
it's the first combination therapy
system that started as a skin care
revolution
um i just feel like i am drawn to
proactive because
there's proof in how long they've been
around and like how how much it's worked
for so many people
um and skin is so unpredictable so you
got to trust the experts at proactive
mm-hmm right now is a great time to try
proactive for our podcast listeners you
can get a special limited time offer
by going to proactive.com toast
subscribe today and you will receive
proactive's hydrating duo as a free gift
that includes four hydrogel masks and
the green tea moisturizer
best of all you get free shipping that
is a lot of free stuff a sensational
deal yes
that's four hydrogel masks and the green
tea moisturizer plus free shipping but
you gotta go to proactive.com
if something has green tea in it it's
it's the thing for you
that is a hundred percent true inside
and outside did you lie
no proactive p r o a c
t i v dot com toast to take advantage of
this special offer that's proactive.com
toast and subscribe to consistently
clear skin
sign on get clear skin first story
yeah girl with no job.com you know i
wasn't going to promote i just wanted
everyone to see like the sickening um
like cover i don't know if they've seen
it yet
no i'm you could go i'm just really i
feel like this this one needs all of
your attention there are some later
stories
where you can promote your vote and
story and you guys i promise this is the
second to last show
well i'll still be promoting really
heavily next week but second to last
show where like i can promote something
that you guys can't have in your hands
starting tuesday it'll be less
frustrating because you'll be able to
have money we can do like
available at growth no job.com in your
hands we could do like a read along
everyone open to page 50 in your
textbook yeah and like the morning toes
will just be silent because it'll be an
hour of time that you should dedicate to
reading my book
yeah and you just hear people's
breathing yeah okay first story you guys
this is what the kids are up to sabrina
carpenter addresses olivia rodrigo drama
on new song skin
okay like i feel like for like half the
population like everyone knows exactly
what that means
and the other half it's like who are
these people i'm so glad you said that
so just a quick refresher we've been
speaking about it the last two weeks
olivia rodrigo star of high school
musical the musical of the series
was dating her co-star joshua bassett
but they've never really eaten they like
had a thing but she was also underage so
they were never super public about it
but it was like they were gonna wait for
each other yes
um at some point before their big coming
out happened
they broke up and he started dating
sabrina carpenter who is also a disney
channel star who was older than olivia
and she's really honestly
everything of the sort like you guys
might know her from tall girls she plays
the sister
she's also the star of one of the stars
of girl meets world yeah but like
for the audience i don't know anything
about this yet you've probably seen her
in
tall girl and i think she also in
dumplin i think so yeah she's like a
netflix contract obviously
yeah yeah she's really she's really
crowded star and she's
so like she's a great singer she's like
it's the the worst type of girl like for
you to hate like if you're olivia
rodrigo because
sabrina carpenter is like multi-talented
and so sweet we've actually met her
she's like such a nice girl
right so it's tough so olivia rodrigo
like
she's a singer songwriter she put out a
song called driver's license that was
all about
her breakup with joshua and how he's
moved on with sabrina carpenter there
was
one line about sabrina she's like the
older girl yeah
you're probably with that blonde girl
who always made me doubt she's so much
older than me
yeah yeah she's everything i'm insecure
about that song came out
and it broke every single streaming
record of all time it happens to be an
incredible
song and so now the three people
involved are
doing their part to tell their side of
the story joshua bassett put out a song
a week later that was actually pretty
decent um but after further
investigation i came to the conclusion
that the joshua basset song like isn't
really about
the driver's license saga because
there's a post on his instagram from two
years ago
of him like in his room on the piano
like playing that song so he obviously
wrote it a really long time ago
okay um but i think he definitely
released it now because
to ride the coattails of olivia's
success yeah he probably looked through
all the songs he's written in the past
which one applies to the situation
done he had to release something because
this is like this is a record-breaking
song in the music industry not just for
disney but like for literally anyone and
i don't know how many
i'm sure there were people on the edge
of their seats wondering what he had to
say but i also think it was like an
opportunity
for him to get his music out there and
like look we're talking about the
morning toast we're 10 years older than
this man yeah
it is it worked a big opportunity now
sabrina carpenter has put out a song
called
skin sort of sharing her side it is
very clearly about this very clearly so
i'm going to read some of the lyrics
starts out maybe we could have been
friends if i met you in another life
maybe then we could pretend there's no
gravity in the words we write
maybe you didn't mean it maybe blonde
was the only rhyme
the only rhyme she said want my heart to
be bro
i'll just read all the ways read all of
it yeah i want my heart to be break and
break it no
i'm happy and you hate it hate it oh and
i'm not asking you to let it go
but you've been telling your side so
i'll be telling mine
you can try to get under my skin under
my skin
under my skin while he's on mine
yeah all on my all on my skin
i wish you knew that even you can't get
under my skin
if i don't let you in sounds like she
got under her skin though
it does honestly the song another one is
it's just so good
like i think she all of her music is
really good but i was listening to the
song and considering
she turned this around in two weeks yeah
joshua bassett probably didn't but like
the production
the vocals the lyrics are there i don't
think there's anything mean i feel like
this song is so like
you know uh
nice honestly like maybe what like yeah
we could have been friends like she's
not slamming her
oh i told and i feel like this is so
like of
this era where it's like let's all be
friends instead of
back in the day when it was like taylor
swift wrote that song about talking
about you know yeah like yeah but you're
you're so wrong the song is so mean
why because wonder why the entire song
is about olivia
whereas olivia's entire song was about
the guy there was one line about sabrina
carpenter but the whole thing was about
like how heartbroken she is over the guy
whereas like
sabrina's song isn't about how happy she
is with joshua bassett
it's all you're not gonna get under my
skin like it's all about olivia rodrigo
i actually like first of all i think
olivia rodrigo and joshua bassett while
i understand that they
their teams probably thought it was
beneficial for them to release songs
like off the success
of a driver's license and they'll never
be driver's license but there'll be more
successful songs than they would have
been otherwise
but it does seem really illusory to me
like like driver's license is so big so
number one like to stop
oh i disagree i feel like even though
her initial song wasn't so much about
sabrina carpenter i don't think sabrina
carpenter can log on to instagram
and see anything other than commentary
about driver's license
pitting her against olivia blah blah
blah and so i think that
even this lyric she says you're telling
it how you see it like truth is whatever
you decide some people will believe it
and some will read between the lines
like
she's saying you know that's your story
and this is mine she's not saying you're
a liar this didn't happen
i just think this is as kind as a diss
track
can be you know i feel like i think the
overall message of like
you know if it had gone differently
maybe we could have been friends okay
she said that one time in the beginning
like i but she she led with that line i
don't know and i think that i
totally just i feel like these girls
could be friends i totally disagree
i think like to make a whole song about
olivia when olivia did not make a whole
song about you and yes the world
interpreted it
found out it was you and is blowing up
your instagram that is not olivia's
fault
no but she's not saying anything mean
about olivia it just seems so petty to
like make a whole song about a girl
younger than you
it petty this is this whole thing is
petty why no i don't think it's petty
starting from the beginning like for
elena to have written a song about her
breakup
that's what people do they write songs
about love about breakups right and
she's writing a song about
what she's experiencing and being like
the talk of the town i just think it's
petty and i think that like
to make the whole thing about olivia is
kind of lizarry i don't think the whole
thing is about her
the whole song is about olivia like i
think that this is as classy around as
she could have taken i think a classy
rap would just have been like to write a
song about her new relationship
not like the girl that your boyfriend
used to date
that's petty i don't think it's petty
like i think that
everyone wants uh her side of the story
and i don't think there's anything wrong
with what she said oh
i um i don't know if other people do but
like i was not interested in her side of
the story like we stand olivia rodriguez
house said in her side of the story in
terms of like how do you feel about the
last two weeks like you just had
a seemingly like blah relationship with
this
guy from disney channel and all of a
sudden it's like front page news because
someone's feelings got hurt like how do
you feel about that part and i feel like
that's exactly what you said she's
saying it's not going to get under her
skin
then why write a song about it i feel
like i got what i wanted to know from
sabrina i think she's doing well and
also like i mean if this were me and i
were her and like i was dating this like
younger guy from disney and
i would be like into this mess goodbye
i could not agree more like sabrina
carpenter is like 21 right
i don't know i think joshua bassett is
18 and i think olivia rodriguez 17. and
honestly
i completely agree if i was dating this
guy no matter how much i liked him and
like i
was into this like teenage mess goodbye
boy
yeah goodbye yeah i just i'm not a fan
of the song i'm not a fan of sabrina or
joshua i stand over rodrigo in this
house you're not a fan of sabrina
not in this instance but i actually
really like spirit carpenter i think
that like your feelings about someone
given everything that she's done up
until this point in her life like should
translate into a situation no i'm
treating this incident as an isolated
incident this is a love triangle
and honestly at the end of the day i
don't really feel like anyone did
anything wrong like that's how i feel
too you're allowed to break up with
someone and you're allowed to date
someone else that's not illegal it's not
a crime
but feelings are feelings so it's like
of course i'm gonna empathize with the
girl who got left behind
yeah you know because in a lot of ways i
am her
oh my god i don't think you've ever had
less in common with the person
no i know cause like she's talented and
i'm not um but i'm happy for her
know that you are yeah i feel like
honestly she would have chosen you know
the success of her song over her life
with joshua bassett any day
percent and if she wouldn't like then
she's like the girl
okay speaking of more messy
relationships
the bachelorette's dale moss has been
accused of cheating on claire crawley
throughout their entire engagement
yes e news broke yesterday that
apparently he
had was seeing someone else like the
entire time they were together
um and now they have released who she is
and she's a real estate agent
in new york um
she apparently claire like knew who she
was and was like skeptical the entire
time and
dale just this is a sabrina carpenter
olivia rodrigo joshua bassett like
situation
just kept saying like they were work
contacts whatever but like
he was nothing of the sort he he's
[ __ ] around
yeah i mean i mean i think it's i mean
it's all bad but
i feel like before this just news just
broke i thought
he was sort of like going out meeting
someone like not really acting like he
had a fiance back at home
but the fact that it seems as though he
had like a whole other girl committed a
relationship yeah
is not good yeah i mean honestly
i just feel like he wasn't showing up
you know and that's that's tough
or he was showing up for too many people
yeah or no he yeah
exactly like this is this is just
devastating you know i was really hoping
he would show up
yeah i feel really bad for claire like
even more so now that like
this is really the absolute worst case
scenario this man was lying to the
entire time and
i just really in in order to seek out
any sort of justice for claire
i really don't want to see dale in
paradise yeah i mean
honestly yes i do feel really really bad
for claire because
not only was she so wrong did she
scramble such an opportunity
but on like the most public of stages
the most public of forums and like now
everyone's like claire like this is why
you're saying
like shut up like no i don't feel i
don't get any pleasure in saying we told
you so
yeah of course cause like you think
claire wants to be single like
she tried her best leave her alone yeah
even though like would i have done it
that way
absolutely not absolutely not i just
hope that dale like doesn't
get what he wanted out of this whole
situation which is probably just startup
yeah that's true you know but he will
i don't know we never saw jed on
paradise
that's true i feel like they would have
had him if he wanted though i think he
was like so done with being embarrassed
by this franchise
yeah tbd tbd but um keeping prayer
keeping claire in my prayers yeah i'm
praying for claire
yes next story we have some bev ben news
gigi hadid has revealed the name of
her and zane's four-month-old daughter
in a super low-key way she changed her
instagram bio
to kai's mom and i heard she was
inspired by instagrammer claudia ashrae
who's had theo's mom in her bio for
years and i think she was inspired by
olivia
whose bio i believe is michaela's mom oh
is it and the pups with no job whose bio
is michaela's cousins oh that's cute
really cute i mean so obviously i think
this is such a cute bio
such a beautiful name do you think kai
is short for anything
i don't know um i have a theory on this
would you like to hear it because this
is like such a low-key subtle way for
like such a major announcement
and i feel like gigi like when she
announced her pregnancy and then her
birth like
somewhere along the way she just like
forgot to announce a name and then it's
like now it's been four months the
baby's like
basically going to college and she like
forgot so like she just like slid it in
her biome like hoped no one would notice
maybe or i feel like this has been
happening a lot too where it's like
the name leaked someone's going to
publish it so let's just do it ourselves
that's actually i want to say a better
theory
yeah or maybe like in the beginning she
wanted all this privacy and just didn't
want people's input or opinions
and now that she's like on to next phase
she's like okay and i'll tell you what i
did there you know i like that she's not
making such a big deal about everything
and me too also i have so much respect
for how much privacy she's seeking out
me too i feel like she's also just like
living the life i've been i don't know
why she's something with the algorithm
her stories are just like coming up in
my feed way more now
um and like all she does is like chill
on the farm like eat ribs with zayn
all day like they're just living their
best life that's so beautiful i don't
know if they're still in pennsylvania or
if they're back in new york
um because like zane's album came out
i'm sure he had like some work to do
but um i'm just like everything's
virtual now yeah i know
so they had this like bus like a
album i don't know cool yeah okay some
more
bebe news sassy schroeder shared the
first photos of her
newborn bebe named hartford charlie rose
clark
charlie rose i wonder if they thought
about that they definitely did and i
think that they were like we're okay
with it okay
i mean was charlie rose disgraced in the
metoo movie
i believe so that's tough yeah but the
name's not charlie rose it's hartford
charlie rose anyway sassy writes beau
and i have spent the last couple of
weeks enjoying every moment with our
daughter oh my god i almost said it like
daughters oh my god my
daughter spot mitzvah is this weekend
can't wait for
you to see her beautiful dress and her
magilla love you
bye don't forget the cannolis
you were saying every cuddle every sound
every poop
all of it it's her two-week birthday and
i feel like i'm finally ready to share
my little girl
meet hartford charlie rose clark the
best thing that's ever happened to me
my heart is so freaking full i can't
believe i get to keep her
i actually really love the name stassi
clark
it's like a you know it sounds like a
really like
famous detective you know yeah did she
change her name
uh on instagram stashy schroeder clark
oh cute and i think when you have a baby
like you start to yeah you start to
incorporate yeah that's
a married name that's at least what i
keep telling them
[Laughter]
again no one we have kids um totally i
think it's a beautiful name i'm really
happy for her the pictures are so cute
the bebe is the sweetie
she's um i feel like she's gonna become
like a rach parcell like big mommy
blogger
you think so yeah because i think i was
talking about this on heather mcdonald's
podcast when i went on like she was
asking like as a canceled person
yourself like where do you see stassi's
business like going
and i think definitely stassi is going
to be offline in terms of like working
for a little bit longer just because
she's like now on maternity leave
but i i do think she's going to come
back with some sort of podcast and i do
think it's gonna be mommy focus because
like
the entertainment pop culture like
fashion world that she was in like
her name has kind of been smeared yeah
that's so interesting
i feel like i feel like i wouldn't be
surprised if
another network picks up the vanderbunk
girls
for a tv show yeah oh that would be
shocking
it would be but i think that i think
well lala is still on
yeah and so is sheena so it would just
be britney and
stassi no but i think that la la i don't
know if vanderpump is ever coming back
i think that's a radio andy that it is
okay i think that
lala would go with the vanderbumps i
think sheena is not she wouldn't
and i think that um the three of them is
enough for a show for sure and then
randall jacks
kristen and katie would probably join um
i don't know about katie but kristen
yeah
katie wouldn't because tom tom kristen
100 um
i don't i don't know if it's coming back
but i do think the ones that are still
employed like
they've been on the air for eight years
they're making somewhere between 30 and
40 thousand dollars an episode
yeah i don't know i just i feel like
definitely a podcast but i i i think
it'll be mommy focuses what i was gonna
is what i was saying like
rage parcel vibes oh rache parcell i've
been like stalking her
so hard like swiping up on all of her
swipe ups um
and i just love her so much i love her
so much i'm watching downton
abbey and i've realized that she looks a
lot like mary crawley
that doesn't mean anything to you and i
also realize that it's all about the
crowley family the show
claire crawley and it's also all about
the parcel of emily
it is all about the parts of the
similarities between the parts
and abbey is just did you see them going
too big i did
of course i did of course oh my god
let's go tubing i know we actually
probably could go too big like upstate
yeah we should just do that okay let's
plan the trip are you ready for a fifth
and final story oh my god already no
is it the fifth and final story brought
to you by my memoir yes the one that's
available at girlsnowjob.com yes
oh thank god what are the odds this is
my book you guys it's a [ __ ]
masterpiece it's 240 pages if you buy
the ebook or the hardcover book and the
inside there are a lot of photos of
moments that i reference in the book
and things you've never seen family
photos my dad likes a bunch of good
stuff
um so please just pre-order my book like
i've been shelling it so hard and
honestly
the pre-order numbers are very strong
and i cannot thank everyone enough for
just
getting their ebooks getting their
audiobooks getting their hardcover books
it means so much to me i cannot wait for
everyone to read this
thank you for putting up with me for the
last few weeks but in case you're still
nervous
just i want you to know like you can do
it you can go to girlsnowjob.com and you
can pre-order this book
and it will change your life yeah also
you know what's nice about a pre-order
well now we're getting so close but
usually you pre-order it you forget
about it and then one day you just get a
package it's like when drunk use shops
for sober you it's again
something shows up and you're like i
didn't order anything and you know when
you suffer from amnesia like i do every
package is a surprise
seriously yeah also i had a an
interesting idea that i
was going to talk to you about offline
but since we're here like everyone can
can hear because we're doing the
redheads episode we're recording it the
day that your book comes out
and then that doesn't give people a lot
of time to read the book and ask
questions
so i think if anybody has extra
questions that they don't get in in time
for the redheads
we'll do like a bonus episode for
patreon with even more questions
that's a great idea i think that would
be really fun okay fifth and final story
you actually sent this to me
erica jane reportedly moves into a 1.5
million dollar home amid tom gerardi
divorce
you guys this thing is getting so real
so crazy there's
they say he's very sick yeah they're
every day there's like a story about
the divorce and the lawsuits and we
don't go into all of it and i
it feels like in the beginning you were
like just
disbelieving yeah and it's like there's
always saying stuff about them but they
you know remain strong yeah no but like
they're filming now she's moved out
she's like posting all of this stuff to
her instagram that's like
she's talking yeah like all these like
new photos they look like great photos
for aya
you know well she also now is really
gonna need to be like a full-time
housewife slash influencer
yeah financially yeah she's got to get
her content in check yeah and
and already is in check yeah but i'm
sure it's like it's just different when
you're choosing to do it of course erica
jane reportedly downsized her home amid
an impending divorce and mounting
financial troubles for the star
according to the blast the 49 year old
reality star moved out of her lavish
home with ex-embattled attorney tom
gerardi
and is living at a smaller residence in
la the 1920s spanish style home
is a three-bedroom two-bathroom property
that is described as charming on its
realtor.com listing
shady page shading shading so the new
york post has the photos and honestly
the house looks super cute and i can
like see it be
there being scenes film there and yeah i
mean
it's not to sound so jaded but
a million dollar house in la is
literally like
not that big mm-hmm and compared to the
houses we've all watched selling suns
right that's what i'm saying like and
you watch selling sunset and you're like
this is a 4 million
house you could see your neighbor's
penis like it's all so tight so like one
million dollars does not get you a lot
in l.a like at all
so but the pictures of this house like
do you look really nice maybe because
it's three bedrooms
it's small yeah it's small so it's just
going to be like a huge um
disparity between the homes of the other
women and now the home of erica jane
and i'm just like i'm i'm just not ready
to see like you know
an erica jane down on you know down on
her luck down on her luck i'm really not
because she i just i love her life i
need
i need some billionaire financier who
like
just wants to support her lifestyle like
that is just so backwards because she
can take care of herself like she really
can if anybody can it's her but i don't
i just want her to like have the option
to like work or stay in her chapel you
know like yeah that's the life i want
for her
i understand but i i feel like reading
this news now it's like oh erica jane's
down on her luck but i feel like when
she's on
when when we watch it on beverly hills
like it's not going to read that way at
all like i think it's going to be very
empowering for her
i actually agree and i do think the
journey of who will erica jane date next
because none of the women in beverly
hills are single i don't think
it'll be very i don't know actually is
kathy hilton married yes
she is um i think that it'll be very
exciting to like cartel single oh
son has a boyfriend but garcelle is
single right now garcelle and erica out
on the town like
that's a storyline we need searching for
rich men
yes that'll be good yeah i just i i just
i'm not really interested in seeing like
a sad erica jane and i just hope that
she doesn't give that to us
yeah i agree and i don't think she's
capable of it so i think that
it's going to be really interesting yeah
um
that's our fifth and final oh great oh
well i don't have another ad um so just
buy my book
and let's talk about southern charm
let's talk about southern charm the
second half of the party which was super
messy but the party looked so fun
oh my god the party was starting to like
really look unfun
honestly oh well then when it started to
rain no but like it was just the longest
day like to go from like swimming and
then you change for a dinner where it's
like so awkward
and it was just looked all over the
place when catherine arrived the vibe
definitely shifted to a negative place
it started like last episode the party
looked fun this episode and also we've
been at that party now for two weeks
yeah
um it just was like reminding me of the
scary island
party they had it was also yeah that
party was terrible it was also
just like difficult to watch because i
really couldn't take a side
like i love madison but she was being
nuts against danny
and i literally just like my least
favorite character on reality tv as of
all time
is danny baird but like madison was
wrong and then they were just like both
being so insane and
i don't even i can't even follow the
storyline anymore i didn't even know
what they were fighting about and then
that conversation with katherine was so
every conversation with katherine was so
frustrating because it's like
you know what you're grown up like take
some [ __ ] accountability
yes your friends should know that that's
not who you are but you did something
really bad
so it made them question it put them
questions to rest and start acting like
an adult like
she was being so childish and so
frustrating and honestly like
love is right like the way everyone's
cuddling her like she's a child it's
like so stupid like grow
up you made a mistake take
accountability for it and stop being mad
that everyone doesn't just automatically
not believe what they're reading because
you actually did that [ __ ] so you made
people question you and now take some
[ __ ] accountability my god it's so
infuriating
yeah sorry no i think that's where
everybody was at
like i've really tried to give her grace
like
because it was a weird season everyone
was separated maybe she'd have a chance
to apologize or explain herself
but no she had like multiple
opportunities on this last night's
episode
and she squandered every single one of
them well by the end that's what i was
going to say about the episode is
98 of it was like really frustrating
watching everyone like chase each other
to have conversations the conversations
going sideways what are we fighting
about like madison
who i really love it was just all over
the place and by the way at that party
she was off her rocker
in everything in every sense and i and i
want to talk about her in a little bit
but
90 of the episode extremely frustrating
i thought that the way that it ended and
the conversation that
catherine wound up having with the girls
ended on
a a pretty good note i really loved what
levi said about their children like yes
how
they can change the past and the future
can be different
for their two kids and like that i
thought was a beautiful
note to end on agreed the episode did
seem kind of choppy like it just ended
in two seconds and then there was like a
six months later thing oh the six months
later thing was really weird especially
considering i think
it's clear that catherine is not right
she actually at the reunion looked like
she lost weight
right so yeah i agree um
by the end though i felt like the season
the whole season was all over the place
but i felt like they they pulled it out
at the end yeah it is silly though for
like you know a 30 year old woman with
two kids like who needed to be badgered
into understanding like why
sending a monkey emoji was bad like i
just
it was so frustrating because like
i don't know but leva had incredible
patience with her
yes and then watching leba and watch
what happens live last night i feel like
added so much context to
a lot of what we've been saying about
this season because i think a lot of
people have been feeling like and it
does seem like you know all leva
does is talk about catherine wants to
have a conversation with catherine it's
catherine catherine catherine
and levi said i'll watch what happened
live last night like the katherine story
was in the news it was top of mind for
everyone
in the cast like it was big news for
them and she just wanted catherine to
have this conversation
sooner rather than later so that they
could move on from it and
move forward right and honestly i feel
like whatever they did
to leva in the editing like they kind of
did her journey because i almost didn't
even like
recognize her personality on watch
robin's life she was just so different
than like the level we've gotten to know
on the on the tv and i thought she was
so like funny and cool and interesting
we didn't see any of that in the show
but on what happens live i'm like who is
this girl yeah no watching her and watch
what happens live last night and it
makes me really excited for the reunion
because her and catherine are friends
yeah it seems like they're good and i
feel like on the reunion
you know of course there's editing but
who you are is
more of who you are so i'm actually
really looking forward to the ring and
like i said the other day i think the
worse the season in this the better the
reunion is because when it's a great
season it's because we're getting
questions answered
you know fights are happening yeah uh
like
closure and there was none of that on oc
the season or southern charm because of
the way it was filmed so i think that
the reunion
next week will be really good i agree um
let's talk about madison because she was
just acting like an absolute lunatic
even though i love her
she's so wrong in the whole austin thing
she's so when she was like is he looking
like she was just being so lazy and
honestly
kind of beta yeah no i
i love her so much and i just and i
i'm this is why i extra don't like the
madison austin relationship because it
makes me dislike both of them and i
actually like both of them
so for that reason they need to stay
away from each other because they're
making the other one unlikable
but when she was just like being so
extra at the party
like everything she was doing going up
to the treehouse and it's funny because
when you look at the conversation like
um the girls were looking being like are
the boys bullying her and when they cut
to the audio it's like no she's going
yeah all three of them
she was being insane yeah she was being
insane and then
that insanity carried over to her
conversation with danny
and i realized afterwards and i think
because annie mentioned it and watch
what happens live
i think that the two of them have a lot
of leftover beef from last season with
the std thing
yes i think so i think that it's like
nothing could happen yet the two of them
just like
are ready to go they've been waiting to
like get back in the ring right no
that's a really good point
right i also thought um shep was so cute
on watchdog inside him i just feel like
he's grown up you know
uh-huh i think that his relationship is
so so cute and really this season he's
just like in this honeymoon phase of
like
we just want to be together the two of
us get in the water and he said because
we love swimming but so they could take
their mics off
oh interesting because that's like the
only time you're allowed to take your
mic off on a reality show it's like if
you go in the pool
or in the ocean no i think that his
girlfriend is such is so
well matched for him and i also think
that like
the way that being in a relationship
relationship helps him navigate these
social situations like
makes him enjoy being in a relationship
like he's really seeing i feel like
he was relationships are all
responsibility no perk
and he's seeing the perks yeah that's
really good good point
um everyone looks amazing at the reunion
catherine died her hair blonde everyone
looks like they really showed up and
showed out
so i'm excited for that and it's um
it was a good season it was not bad
given the coveted stuff like it wasn't
oc
and it wasn't you know potomac like it
was somewhere in between yeah
and you're right um now that i'm
thinking about it when was last time
vanderpump rules was on the air
um the beginning of quarantine and i
don't think they've started filming it
no they haven't but it's also because
restaurants aren't
la is like totally oh right um and i'm
sure that you know restaurants will open
and
they'll continue filming banner pump
rolls again but like the last
season was so bad a lot of the mainstays
are gone
i think that they have their work cut
out for him then like at this point all
they really have is the title of the
show right maybe they should just start
over like maybe they really do they take
the show to vegas
and they do vanderpump garden something
um so yeah those were the tv shows that
we watched last night i didn't watch
anything else except oh i did
i did watch my first episode of jeopardy
with ken jennings
and it's good like he does the job
totally fine but he does lack this sort
of
um emotion you know like when someone
got an answer wrong like you could
literally feel alex trebek like wanting
to cry for the person he's like no
it was jackie ash right you know where
as
ken jennings does this weird thing where
i couldn't get over it he literally
sings he's like no
next one he was just like lacking this
sort of connection to the players
that's a good insight but it wasn't bad
by any means if you just watch it and
you're not like a crazy jeopardy fan
like he does the job very well he
doesn't stutter he reads the
teleprompter he reads the prompts very
well he knows all the answers he adds
his weird little
it was actually the ancient egyptians
you know so he does good on the surface
but there's more to being a jeopardy
host than reading what's on the cards
yep
i feel that but again this was his first
week and i only caught one episode it's
like the sort of thing that you can't
fake or teach well it does seem like the
sort of thing you can't fake or teach
but that does
develop over time being more comfortable
like
a magic and imagine like the shoes
trying 100
i i hear you um um so that's our show
anything else you want to say before we
wrap this mother up oh just so excited
to head into the weekend i just want to
thank the weekend for coming you know
it's just so exciting this
is thank you so much for being here like
we know how busy you are yeah i just
it's so wonderful so i'm really gonna
just soak it all in and soak up each
other's
awesomeness that's what i was gonna say
it's like the weekend has never been
we've never had more weekend in front of
us than we do right now and i just i
want to encourage everyone who's
listening close your eyes
take a deep breath remember this moment
acknowledge this moment acknowledge the
blessings you have in front of you
not one but two days off two days of
alarm free living and you know tomorrow
it'll be great but you'll only have one
day left
so you'll never have more hope on the
horizon than you do right now
just relish it enjoy it breathe it in
suck it up
and soak up each other's awesomeness we
will see you on monday
thank you so much for listening to the
morning test the millennium morning show
where we deal with the facility stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe give this video a
thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitch or public radio i
have already cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows leave a five star view
about our beautiful stunning and smart
we are
we hope you have an amazing weekend stay
safe and we will see you on monday
[Music]
goodbye